as the DUIs line is out here is gabov a shot
attempt is Block it's played ahead and here's a
break eel look out in shoots stick save is made oh
a big stop early on by Cam telin that might be a
key at least to create something Fourth Man second
wave lafier ahead for dub and on go a chance
kicked out rebound scar lefair a he bangs home the
rebound chance for the game's first [Music] goal
I've been told that PL DUIs is moving faster than
he looks neutral zone taking care watch this du
gets it right there look at this he actually
shielded the puck before he got the puck he
wanted to make sure we follow number eight here
watch this he'll let the puck do the work gets
his legs in position rebound becomes an issue and
the golender can not F find the second opportunity
here's the call upon review of the play with trono
we have confirmed that we have a good goal so
there it is many times with the Kings and against
the Kings the faier moving in passes across save
is made off Roy oh Thompson got his left arm
on it the puck out of play into Vegas Ice DB B
to the trailer Roy a drive save rebound the faier
couldn't reach it pinballs around fiala on it yeah
tet's play in that first fre reminiscent of his
game in Winnipeg a couple of weeks ago when he was
outstanding in the first period kept the Jets at
Bay and the Kings eventually went on to a 5 to one
win Lewis wrapped up by defenseman hag in for the
puck right corner lazat turns shoots save is made
rebound Anderson a shot save loose pu score Trevor
Lois two nothing [Music] [Applause] La identity
play to it execute it and be effective and this
is all about grind up in it was grundstrom on
the puck then everyone gets involved High look
here look at a bouncing in against the boards
grundstrom making room for line mates his
teammates and then on the back hand so a lot
of things going on here we talked about how well
Vegas does and it's deflected before the rebound
the other way Vegas barbashev for aario in on left
Wing Stops up a shot stick save Rebound dorv with
it takes it to the net moves behind the net walks
out a backhander save score AO on the rebound you
could just tell that the game opened up the
Kings took a two-goal lead and then it became
a rush game a long game as Todd Mullen likes to
call it Kings back and back and back and finally
with a a multiple chance situation here it's not
necessarily clean until the very end there it is
right there you can see what I'm talking about
not clean but you get bodies there you get loose
pucks there and all of a sudden aano on the right
hand shot see tet just looking one way standing up
for his teammate Vegas their first power play
they set it up IO moving in the middle took a
shot save rebound loose whack at it Marsh so but
a stop in tight by Talbot lafier feeds the middle
but picked off kisar check but here comes carier
in on left wing to the net shoots and he scores
so after a great ship for the lant line they vas
comes down and they tie the game but once again
Nick Daryl that long game it it's it's sustained
pressure here's the types of plays I was talking
about earlier you see that attempted pass that's a
hope play the faier unfortunely young player he's
trying to make something happen shot comes in
we've seen it a million times just off the post
so K does a great job here [Applause] but it was
the turnover in the offensive Zone that leads it
feeds for Theodore wrist it down low King are onor
with Roy Roy being hounded lost the puck Center D
of a chance save rebound right in front Creed
Away by the Kings Carson couldn't te it up but
it came loose point shot Theodore stick save talet
saw it all the way out of the LZ groups way they
play out there they go in they cycle it work it
in the trenches they've been successful the other
lines need to follow suit like that decisive move
though by Trevor Moore just taken right to the net
Moore again with a chance and an arm save made by
Thompson there's a decisive move by Moore Vegas
changing Den know with the line of shot stick save
rebound oh save again Thompson didor wristed down
low Center on the wall by lazat but not out held
in Theodore at the goal line they hand it off to
Stone who scores a pass down low and Marsh IO
one touched it to stone for the go-ahead power
play goal yeah the Kings again when they took
the penalty the the pinching defenseman became
a factor that's one thing that the gold Knights
have stepped up here in Period number three to
get the power play and right here with a battle on
the boards from this point on now see what Theodor
does right there he gets the middle of the ice
when you do that it opens up so many other things
it's only two or three steps and then it's the
bunt back look at how quick it happens here marcho
he just wants to draw attention to himself just
for a split second give but then the next wave
that's where it's difficult here is dowy Kings
trying to tie it up a give and go with a shot he
scores Drew dowy set up top of the slot from
Kevin falo to tie the game of three [Applause]
the setup is absolutely perfect the way the Kings
take control F with a pass here okay they dumped
it in right look at that then you have pressure
then you get control the did not try to carry it
in that's a big difference f with the pass now all
the things we to talk about Daryl Drew dowy has
really improved that one timer yeah he really has
makes himself available instead of standing still
he gets himself into a position where the lane
is open Quick Release he in OT Vegas 0 and one
this season kopar out with Kee and dowy against
Carlson iel and Theodore we're underway dowy
chase behind his net brings it up the right side
moves into the middle on his forehand beats it
across Theodore holding back to eel one timer hit
the crossbar or the post opportunity and they did
get it early one timer bang near post right at
the post crossbar up high to Theodore to Stone
to Theodore in the middle Theodore right side eel
can he shoot not yet feeds it down low Carlson to
Stone a shot save his made talin King's going to
clear for I kimpe shoots just wide and there's
the horn oh that would have been a buzzer beater
and win the game Kee that close this year four
of seven in his career Moore picks it up more in
on Thompson shoots save is made and Thompson is
a lefty Trevor likes High glove against righties
so he probably doesn't have the same option here
tried to get the lateral move and he actually
he probably lost the puck there as much as he
wanted to hold a little bit longer go over top
of the pack yeah you could tell he went to a
stick there he looked like he did make the shot he
wanted eel round one of the shootout for Vegas eel
in shoots and scores with eel because he shoots
so a lot of deception and I've seen him do this
before there was no fake there was no nothing
Kevin fiala must score to keep it alive fiala
into the Zone in on goal shoots save Thompson
and Vegas wins the shootout and wins the game